I'll shoot where it looks happy guys I
don't know if you know maybe some of you
know but most of you probably don't I
love drawing I love drawing I've loved
drawing since I was like three years old
and off and on I've been like practicing
you know as a kid I always loved like
how to drop tanks how to drop airplanes
and how to draw like wrestlers and that
drawl just all the good stuff right you
know over time I was trying to figure
out different ways to draw you can use
water color you can use pencil you can
use a pen and you can do it all these
different styles and I came across this
one style
it's like contour drawing you can't pick
up your pen from weight drawing and it's
blind you can't look at what you're
drawing you have 30 seconds to draw your
best friend's face all right let's go up
and see Sam okay hey Sam
let me give you a light-filled nice
classy yeah classic portrait yeah it's
like it's like the panel the squish
panel right you have the randomness of
like I don't know what I'm gonna get but
you might you might get some gold right
you ready there we go
once you do that you elevate it right
you take it to the next level and you
shade it like you shade it really well
it looks and it just looks beautiful
sweet whoa this is Brett son that's
another sign right here this cliff again
will you do to practice drawing wow
that's sweet you would do it do it do it
do it
yeah inktober is the thing where you
like draw something in ink every single
day that helped a lot actually cuz like
at first I was like super careful about
what I did and then over the course of
the month I kind of developed a style
like a sketchy style like this is kind
of the style like what came with a style
it's kind of sketchy and not really like
precise because with a pen you just kind
of like just go with it you know I guess
yeah
this is Sam that's that's actually it
resembles it yeah I like the room that
you can't remove the pen from the paper
yeah that really I think gives it a
whole new level of the bonus challenge
yeah we should we should go around we
should draw everyone and then freaking
frame them dude just bring them up imma
grab pen
and I'm just gonna just draw everyone 30
seconds can't look at it can't pick up
my pen let's try it I've never had my
portrait drawn before you've got to be
horribly to support oh shoot where your
lips at maybe that's where they are you
kind of have to start yet in the center
because then you know like where you're
at and kind of go from there there's
like a perfect photograph that one
dude that's like some sure enough Planet
of the Apes yeah I can see the
resemblance I don't know anything about
this soda other than what Adrienne's
told me about it and I'm really
intrigued I like sour things but this
sounds like it might be too into this
yeah so ever since
Adrienne broke his collarbone he's been
unable to drive and since we live within
like a couple miles of each other I've
just been driving over work everyday
which is not a problem but he you know
has wanted to show his appreciation by
getting me the world's most sour soda
apparently I've no idea what that means
sour sodas I thought you'd like how this
bottle looked I mean I thought the
bottle look pretty badass wait wasn't
this isn't the sneakers that's mine
excuse me that is cool dude wait we need
to get we need to get somebody else an
opinion on this this rule the rule is
you're in the game here in the game and
if he leaves
exponentiate next when she blows up yeah
and then if he doesn't do them right now
for the whole extent of his injury well
you can always pull a jake and just
never fulfill his debt
I shouldn't have asked you I think you
do a one-handed push-up yeah
wait wait wait 100 pushups like a month
ago
a game of the gun credit right hell yeah
I'm turning in my credit I got a broken
clavicle push that you were credit but
now I guess the question is like should
you have to spend the credit do see
everybody long term investments pay off
[Music]
shading we got this janky outline and
I'm gonna try and make it look 3d and
try and render it almost right
essentially anything that's white is
coming towards the camera anything
that's black is going away from camera
and I'll probably just choose a general
light source on the start I'm gonna just
do like the lightest values first and
I'm gonna shade everything at a very
light value as a test to see is this
where I want my lighting to come from
I'm gonna use this paper towel to smudge
it and smear it so it's like super
smooth and it looks just like like baby
smooth you know I mean they sell little
rolls of paper specifically for this it
looks like a pencil but it's made of
paper I got like a general shadow on
this thing and I'm gonna start making
the values darker and darker and darker
and darker so that's the first one it's
about five minutes
nice it render you to drink that drink I
want to see the Shogun for doing that to
me you better chug it
I loved warheads back when I was in like
fourth grade
oh my god it's literally black oh yeah
oh it's nothing
it smells like regular coke but then
after like a moment they like hit my
lungs and then like seized it up
I see warheads so much that would make
my son bleed now still need more tongue
stop stalling yeah drink the soda okay a
little bit not like stop stop stallin
already has been stopped I mean like
stop stalling
alright I'm gonna try
it's not even shower that's what I
thought but it's not like snow yeah
nothing's worse than when juice man hey
well that was interesting
thanks for sharing yeah this is supposed
to be much cooler segment no man time to
reveal the final shots here some of
these turned out looking like really
funny versions of all y'all if some of
these turned out looking like real ugly
versions you guys and some just turned
out not looking like you guys all right
here we go Sam that's you dude that's
art it's like Picasso
I can recognize that if you squint like
it can stand really far away that makes
sense I like those lips yeah what that's
like gay obviously not dude that's
amazing this looks like them like that
like the Beatles yellow submarine
styling art yeah
this is my favorite one I'm Christian
[Laughter]
oh my god
looks so good Nick just slid off
completely from his body and this
basically that's karma karma those eight
flips that eight upper lip sorry all
these pictures on our corridor digital
Instagram at corridor digital on
Instagram go take a look tell us which
one is your favorite tell us which one
is released favorite and most scary let
us know if you use these as our profile
pictures maybe I'm the new banner for
the corner crew channel yeah dude Dobby
day when is Dobby day when is Dobby day
one is Davide when is d-day Dobby day is
the day that Adrian broca's car bomb day
you have the annual pickling in the
morning for your winter stores yeah
pickling we do make pickles and pickle
different things okay followed up by
badminton followed up by Brielle just
drink water for lunch do we all update
creative cloud we make them jump to new
software versions then it's ended with a
rousing game of world Olympic khaki sack
unplug the Internet oh and then we all
have to get one thing unplugged from our
computer and we don't know what it is to
figure out how to fix a day I have to
hold a camera
I always feel sour right here
real hard that's the logos the word head
literally the word